norway's cruise shipping industry has
been brought to a halt amid an outbreak
of coronavirus cases among passengers
on wednesday authorities ordered a
cruise ship to dock in the town of
bordeaux and
all 200 passengers to quarantine it came
just
days after 44 people on board another
ship had tested positive for the virus
the cruise line which was one of the
first to resume sailing in the country
during the pandemic has apologized
we're very sorry for the situation that
has occurred we're working intensively
with the municipality
and national infection control
authorities our main priority is of
course
to take care of our crew members who are
on board the ship and the guests
who have been on board this year
authorities are yet to determine the
origin of that outbreak but
fears of widespread infection have been
heightened by the fact the cruise ship
docked at several ports along norway's
coast allowing
passengers to disembark war pools have
now been ordered to close to cruise
ships for two weeks
and the incident has divided opinion
among norwegians
[Music]
i'm not worried about it there's just as
much reason to be worried about
norwegian tourists who've traveled to
spain or other places in europe
we had to come back to normality
at some point anyways so this is just
one step further down the road
i think it's alarming that they
relaunched so quickly and though they
didn't follow the quarantine rules the
employees on board
but i'm not worried about the infection
spreading to oslo
we spoke with norwegian law professor
eric carosic who
told us the risks posed by the virus are
being dangerously overlooked
the danger of
spreading the virus within a ship
is underestimated by many people
and well they didn't take the necessary
precautions
obviously and in norway the debate has
been very much about
whether the rules actually were
followed but i believe that the rules
are inadequate
for example that there is no
canteen for passengers and crew leaving
the ship
and that there is no
supervision of canteen or other
restrictions
on crew members not boarding
in norway